first i will give you an overview of
what is challenging about deformables
just to introduce kind of this topic why
am i interested in it why we're
generally interested in looking into
that and then just to give you a brief
uh preview of what's going to be in the
talk i will talk about the
distributional approach to representing
the state of the deformable objects then
uh generalizing the work that we're
doing with deformables to incorporate
differentiable simulation and then i
will talk about our current and future
plans for
creating scalable simulation
environments so that we can do large
scale training
so what's difficult about deformables
the biggest problem is that they have
potentially an infinite number of
degrees of freedom and what does this
mean here if you are in robotics then
you are usually used to represent the
position orientation of a
rigid object with for example 6 degrees
of freedom saying 3d for position and 3d
orientation
so that's one big problem because what
what what how can we say what is the
state of the deformable object another
problem is that
uh it is pretty expensive and very
challenging to annotate the state of the
object even if you were to somehow
meticulously place like a lot of
different markers on your object to
track them that would be pretty
challenging and so there are these uh
large uh scanners that could help you uh
track the motion of somebody who for
example a person or person wearing
something deformable or manipulating to
formals but these machines are pretty um
challenging to install and they're very
expensive so ideally we would need
self-supervised or unsupervised methods
so that we can just see what is
happening was it a deformable object
somehow learn from it without having to
label things
the other challenges are as follows we
have occlusions when we are dealing with
objects for deformable and
non-deformable objects but for
deformable objects they're particularly
difficult because if you look at the
objects from different sides
and a second later it can change shape
drastically so you can't even rely on on
trying to kind of uh establish you know
like look around the object and try to
somehow anchor yourself to what sort of
shape it has and and maybe get sort of a
sense of what the object is doing from
that
the other problem is that let's suppose
that you try to reduce the
dimensionality so i said um the
deformable object is potentially you
know like has infinite degrees of
freedom um you could try to map the
representation of that deformable object
into a lower dimensional state uh like
here for example by tracking a few key
points uh on this object but then the
problem is that even if you do this the
uh kind of non-trivial dynamics of that
deformable object will still remain so
in that lower dimensional space you
would have a few key points but they
would be jumping around like seemingly
randomly and very hard for you to figure
out what is actually going on with the
object so we need to cope with ambiguous
state
of the object
potentially being able to handle
occlusions and also the noisy states
because if we for example map the our
high dimensional representation of the
object into low dimensions then for sure
we would have um aggravated also the the
effects of the noise
so in the first part of the talk i'll
share with you uh one of the approaches
that we're taking and this is to use
distributional representations or rather
develop distributional representations
of deformables so we can use uh
unsupervised methods to learn this um
let's say to to map the deformable
object let's say we're just have an rgb
image of this object and how it moves
and then we would be able to using
existing methods extract some key points
from this but then the problem with
these key points is that they would be
kind of permuting and jumping randomly
along uh the lengths of this object and
so the representation would be pretty
challenging to interpret so what we
would like to get is we would like to
get a permutation and variant
representation that doesn't get confused
by these key points jumping along the
surface of the object and we would also
like to for for this to be robust to
occlusions and noise
so at first i'll show you the setup that
we have on hardware when we are dealing
with this so for example here is a
scenario to wind a rope here is a
scenario to fling a highly deformable
cloth into the air and our input would
be these sorts of images that we just
take from our regular rgb camera
that is kind of mounted uh slightly
overhead and on the side this is a
scenario to wipe a table uh with a cloth
that's not a very deformable cloth but
you can have a much more deformable one
as well and uh this is a 3d deformable
object this is a flexible hoop or kind
of a tire and the task here is to
stretch it over these two poles so these
are the scenarios that we're going to be
uh looking at and what we want to do
here is we want to be handling the first
part of the reel to cemetery so that is
real to sim so we have a simulator here
uh and this is this is actually a
simulated uh image that's just an rgb
image and uh what happens here is the
simulator has a cloth and it has certain
parameters for this clause like for
example bending stiffness and elastic
stiffness of this cloth friction and
scale and what we can do is we can uh
here we're not concerned with matching
the visuals like like learning the match
for the visuals we will just initialize
the visual representation of the object
to be fairly similar to what we have in
reality but what we are interested in is
we're interested in finding these
parameters of the simulations or the
physical parameters of the simulation
and we want to not have to
search for them by hand but we want our
algorithm to be able to find them
so overall the uh the overall procedure
is going to be like this we will sample
a bunch of simulated trajectories so for
example here a bunch of different sizes
different bending and and stiffness
properties for uh this rope
and then we will extract the key points
so there are a few standard methods that
are already out there that have been
originally developed for some of them
have originally been developed for rigid
objects but they can somewhat handle the
deformable ones and there are also ones
that have been successfully used in the
deformables before so this is kind of
existing work
and then what we will do is we will uh
create a representation from these key
points that is um not just taking the
key points like in 3d or in 2d here in
coordinates of the image but we will
embed this into a high dimensional space
and i will explain this here in depth so
this so this is the part of the work
that that we're presenting here
so we will interpret these key points uh
that appear along the object uh or or
anywhere on the surface of the object as
samples from the probability
distribution
uh
kind of samples from the surface of the
object and so why is it a probability
distribution because every time we run
this algorithm to extract this key point
depending on the configuration of the
object we would get different kinds of
key points but they will come from the
surface of the deformable
and uh then we will
embed these samples so each of these we
treat as as a sample from a probability
distribution and we will embed this
probability distribution into an
infinite dimensional space and i'll
explain how so why are we trying to do
this this will give us the permutation
and variance and robustness to noise and
this will also so so like why are we
doing uh why are we dealing with
infinite dimensional spaces because this
lets us get a convenient distance matrix
between these distributions between the
distributional embeddings and this way
we will be able to say whether one bunch
of points basically is similar to
another bunch of points in a way that
basically relates the two distributions
as opposed to just like looking directly
at the points
so
now i'll just introduce the background
for what what does this mean embedding
uh mean
uh so it's a
a map of that uh maps the distribution
into an infinite dimensional space here
so here i'm just drawing a cartoon
version of a distribution okay and and
it's mapped into some embedded space
and um the reason why it's interesting
is because it can represent so this kind
of mapping can represent uh the
probability distributions in a non um
in a non-parametric way and without loss
of information and here uh i've given
some background here what does it mean
without loss of information that means
that
this mapping can recover uh all of the
uh
kind of functions
within this space into which we're
mapping that's called the reproducing
colonel hilbert space but within that
space there is a dot product meaning
that we can measure distances between
this distribution and something else so
for example other distributions or other
functions that appear in the space and
while this dot product if we're uh
complete this mapping then by this dot
product we will be able to measure
distances and so what this would give us
is this would give us a very nice
representation for how to basically say
how similar the two distributions are
after the embedding
so now how are we going to do this in
practice
in practice we're not going to have
access to the actual probability
distribution right we're only going to
have samples so these samples are going
to be this x1 through xn and points that
we just get every time we look at a
frame um and we see a deformable object
there and we extract the key points and
the empirical part of it is that we're
going to be taking these samples and
extracting infinite dimensional features
from them and summing them all up and
this will constitute our embedding so
this is kind of a known object and i'm
just outlining here how we're going to
practically do it in this case but one
more step that we need to do to make it
actually uh computable is this fee here
is kind of an abstract object we're like
taking our point and we map into some
infinite dimensional space how would we
do it
um
and so here we're going to use the line
of work that has been around for some
time since uh 2007 that is called uh
random fourier features and in summary
what this does is it lets us use an
approximate mapping fee hat in order to
be able to extract kind of like a finite
dimensional vector from this and still
be able to retain some of the properties
that that we wanted to uh have
originally
all right and so here i will describe
what this mapping is and and this part
is previous work so this can be found uh
in this paper that i've cited here so
after uh going through the math of uh
how we can do this approximation what
will come out of this math is that we
will have basically a bunch of sines and
cosines in a vector and how many sines
and cosines we would have would dictate
how approximate our representation is so
each
sine and cosine vector here would
basically be kind of like picking a
coordinate um and then using that
coordinate and uh basically having a few
parameters where we uh decide kind of
how to map our uh
our
point x here onto that coordinate and
then we would basically pick a bunch of
these coordinates but you have to kind
of use an abstract uh reasoning here so
like these coordinates are actually
functions so we're kind of mapping onto
the space in the space of functions and
each coordinate is a function and if you
remember your signs and cosines they're
kind of some somehow orthogonal uh in
this space and so this is why we can
construct ourselves a very nice
kind of coordinates onto which we're
going to be mapping this but we don't
have to use all of the coordinates like
there's an infinite number of them and
so the interesting part here is that we
will be able to adaptively pick out
which ones of this we're going to end up
using and also how many of them we will
be using will dictate how approximate
our representation would be
so
uh for those of you who know something
about kernel methods maybe you've heard
or you've dealt with them in some other
context the reason why we are also
interested in in this kind of setup is
because uh one can show that if we draw
these uh vectors here randomly from some
distribution like for example from
standard normal uh then we can
approximate a radial basis uh function
kernel and so this is just a remark for
those of you who know about the kernels
and if those people who kind of do
research in in the space of kernels they
have various intuitions about what is
good they can sample from different
distributions to approximate different
kernels and so overall this just nicely
connects to the kernel methods in
general
so i will stop here for a little bit um
because i have basically summarized kind
of what our representation is and i will
let you ask questions and then the last
thing i will say here is that what we
are going to try to do here is we're
going to try to
adjust the parameters that uh basically
pick out which
random vectors we use and how we stretch
these random vectors
we're going to adjust them
via back propagation so the reason why i
call this an arches net layer is because
we're going to put this transformation
here is in a differentiable way into our
networks and then whatever other
algorithms we're going to be using we're
going to be able to adaptively adjust
these parameters
all right so i'll pause here and let
people ask questions
if things are
no questions zoom people
there's your chance
jeanette is going to ask a question
i was going to ask does anyone have a
question on this um
anything on the kernel methods on the
features
anyone
have one quick question which is i just
want to better understand this the dot
product or like how how it shows up
numerically also hi this is treyas oh hi
shares
dot product numerically yes
yes so uh what this says is that uh we
will have a space where the dot product
would make sense and so basically if we
um this is just like a theory part right
if we uh had some function f uh with
this embedded representation we would be
able to compute the expectation of that
function f y the dot product this
relates to just like regular kernel
methods the reason why this is
interesting is because dot product is
related to norms is related to basically
similarities or distances between the
points in the space and so here maybe uh
some function f okay what could this
function be i don't know but in this
particular case we could be interested
in something like an embedding of one uh
distribution and embedding of another
distribution and then what we can see is
we can see okay for these two
distributions
how
how close are they in the sense of how
similar
these two states of the objects are and
so it's basically it's a state
representation of the object where after
the embedding you can say that
because you have a continuous mapping
that is nicely behaved because you have
a mapping where the distances like in
embedded space the distances matter then
you can compare how different the two
distributions are and so that means that
you can compare the two states and
yeah that's that's the usefulness of it
does that answer your question
i assume yes there was another question
another question on the on the keyboard
is this could you replace the key points
with
um a binary mask on the image like
distinguishing
between the background and the object
and using those the big solutions that
i'm doing you could the only problem is
how would you get that mask
yeah exactly so we will actually be
using the mask as a ground truth to do
the evaluation but we will not let any
algorithms see that because i mean you
have to hand construct this somehow the
key points you don't have to do anything
in the case of using unsupervised
methods you throw a bunch of data at the
unsupervised method it learns how to
extract these key points so that's the
benefit of it
any other questions
i think
um yeah i kind of have two
so the first one is
uh the key points themself you're
assuming are like drawn from
some random distribution right some
probabilistic distribution and that
they're uncorrelated
right uh yeah let me explain so the key
points the one assumption that we make
is that they uh are points on the
surface of a deformable object
so they're not drawn from any analytic
probability distribution they're just
whatever method you use to extract them
it says oh okay here is the object
moving i'm going to place some key
points along this object
and um
the second question was
uh well just to follow up on that
is the key point detector does it
account for like temporal dependence
no
it does not right and that's exactly
what we want here so we want our uh key
point extractor to be free to place them
anywhere and if they permute for example
so if in one frame i have a bunch of key
points and then one of these key points
just moves somewhere else on the object
uh that's perfectly fine that's the
permutation and variance that we want to
have in our representation so the one
thing that we do not do here is we do
not do key point tracking through time
like over frames
exactly yeah um the reasoning for that
is that if you can do it great that can
help you wonderfully with rigid objects
with the formables you frequently
either can't or it is very very
difficult you need a lot of data to
somehow establish this correspondence
and so that's why we would want to have
something which does not need like from
from very little data it can
have a representation where you are okay
with the key points for muting and you
can still meaningfully do something with
that representation right plus you could
have a bad initialization
yeah so
what what's the point of so once you
embed the features are you like going to
decode them into these parameters is
that where you're going with this we are
going to go with this yes next right so
we're not going to directly to decode
them but what we're going to use yeah
i'm going to be answering your question
over the next five slides yes um so what
can we do with this right so we get this
representation we plug it into some
neural network that is going to learn
something useful for us uh here what
we're doing is we're doing real-to syn
so we're trying to get some sort of a
real data and figure out which
simulation parameters are most likely
to generate this data and we're going to
plug this into a method that is called
basesim this was at rss 2019 and a
version of this method what it does is
it trains a mixture density network to
take input trajectories and output a
gaussian mixture distribution over the
simulation parameters so the here the
simulation parameters were bending an
elastic stiffness friction and scale
and you know you can have arbitrary
parameters here whatever it is that your
simulator can vary the training
objective for this would be just data
log likelihood and so the way that we
would train this initially is we would
take simulator trajectories and you can
generate a bunch of them train this
network um and then you would basically
have a mapping from the input trajectory
to the probability distribution over the
simulation parameters and here what i
will be showing as results is comparison
of uh when you take as input adjuster
trajectories meaning just to the key
points versus when you pass them through
this rkhsnet layer that does this
distributional uh representation and
then you pass this through this network
so ultimately uh to answer chris's
question what we're going to be doing
here is we're going to be training this
intermediate thing here that will then
help us to infer the distributions over
simulation parameters and that is our
real to sim problem
so after this network is trained we're
going to give a real trajectory um to
as input and we're going to infer the uh
distribution of our simulation
parameters that is most likely um
for kind of for this kind of trajectory
and then what we can do after this is we
can actually repeat all of this over and
over in order to make these
distributions more peaked so we can
collect the next uh batch of simulation
simulated data kind of more narrowly
around the regions which are more likely
then again uh retrain uh the um base
mixture density network then get another
trajectory from hardware or use the same
trajectory and obtain more peaked
posteriors so this is what we're going
to be doing with it
now
to show you what this comes up with is
here an example for the results with the
winding scenario where we extract the
key points we we mask out the robot here
because we know the state of the robot
we know its shape we know where it is so
we don't really worry about what the
robot is doing but we don't know
anything about the deformable so we just
have an rgb image of this and here as i
mentioned we're going to be first using
unsupervised key points and to evaluate
here we're going to measure the distance
to the ground true state and this is
what somebody else was asking can you
get a mask so here just for evaluation
purposes we would say
okay just based on the uh colors here
make a mask for where the deformable is
and compare how well did you uh how well
is your
simulation that is sampled with the
parameters from the result
how well does it align with the actual
real
image
and what i'm showing here as results is
comparison for this base sim method
using the um inputs just as is so just
keep points or using another way of just
using random fourier features without
the distributional embedding and so
these are these two lines and then these
two lines are using the uh
distributional embedding as i described
before it was just slightly different
ways of learning the mixture density
network so
um that's the result for unsupervised
key points you can also use supervised
methods that have been specifically
developed for handling deformables and
here you can see uh for for this kind of
object they're pretty noisy so that's
that's going to be difficult for
the method to handle if you don't have
the distributional embedding but if you
do have the distributional embedding
then again you can reduce the distance
to the ground truth quite a bit
we also compared to batch methods here
on the side where or i say bulk here
where we just uh for all of the data
that these algorithms would ultimately
see we just collect this data ahead of
time we don't do anything iterative and
we just batch train either a simple
neural network or a simple uh gaussian
process and then see how well we can
recover the uh parameter the simulation
parameters
so similarly uh we can go to the other
scenarios uh these are unsupervised key
points for the fling task and these are
supervised ones so you can see the
supervised ones they can be very nicely
placed kind of uh almost on the corners
of the cloth so that could be nice but
the problem is that if they permute then
you kind of
have an even noisier uh result because
you have managed to rely on this
representation being somehow coherent
and then with the noise it uh tricks you
and and you can potentially have
difficulties so which is shown here with
this uh yellow and green line and then
in the case where we're using the amine
embedding again we can reduce the
distance to the ground truth uh quite a
bit better and so this is the result
with the supervised key points
and similarly
with the wiping task
here we have this problem where the
robot mask didn't work out so well for
the um
unsupervised key points but we can we're
still able to get a reasonably good
result even with this kind of problem
and for the supervised key point uh case
these are kind of nearly perfect always
place on the corners very nice and so
you can see that the baseline algorithms
here they're doing a little bit better
but still again the key points can
sometimes permute and that's why they
can be a bit confusing still and this is
our last example with this deformable uh
hoop or attire again you can see here
that the key points can be noisy not
only permuting in different places of
the object but also kind of being kind
of left over extraneous noise and that
can still be um
can still be okay for
the
algorithms that are using this mean
embedding
all right and this is with the
supervised keypoints which is the few
key points placed on the hoop
okay so what we have here is an ability
to get an inference over the probability
distribution of simulation parameters
that would make the simulation behave
most like reality
we can do this from just a single real
trajectory or potentially we can go on
and continue to get new uh trajectories
and even if there's something that is
changing in our scenario or in the
dynamics of the objects
this can still kind of function in such
a way that we can shift our posteriors
and we can obtain newer and newer
results and so this can dynamically let
us kind of adapt our resulting
simulation to something that we see in
reality
so
for this part uh we're good if people
have more questions i can answer them
but i think we had quite a few before so
now i'm gonna give just a brief snapshot
of
our uh current work and this work is to
generalize this a bit so
previously what we had is we had a what
we call black box simulator where we
can't pass the gradients through that
simulator just you know we can
create some you know simulation
parameters run the simulation and get
some sort of an output and here we are
using a
differentiable simulator and we are also
able to work with point clouds so
instead of just being able to like
see the image um and just do something
with that rgb image here we're going to
be taking a look at
whether we can use uh the point cloud of
the object so this is work that is done
with a phd student who was rotating in
our group priya uh cinderella and here i
will just go very briefly over the setup
so i won't go too much in depth but just
to give you an idea of how this can be
done so our input is point cloud that is
obtained from these two cameras one
overhead and one on the side um and uh
what we're going to do is okay our
objective here again is to infer the
simulation parameters so that's going to
be kind of like our output in a sense
like the the desired question that we
want to answer
and what we'll do is first we will run
this physics engine in order to simulate
to the deformable so for example this
piece of cloth here that we're lifting
up then we'll get the mesh states of
this deformable but then the key part
here is that we need to uh basically
plug this into a differentiable
rendering framework where we can connect
the
not the mesh states but the points uh
sampled from this from this mesh to be
able to compare that with the real point
cloud and then if we do this in a
differentiable manner then what we can
do is we can pass back the gradient all
the way through the mesh states through
the
dynamics of the uh simulator here to
adjust the simulation parameters which
here is the stiffness and mass for
example and then we keep on going uh do
this a few times
and so here um
let's see this is going to be playing
right i'm going to show
uh what freya has done in her
experiments with the real cloth and real
point clouds being able to infer
the
um
the the kind of stiffness of the cloth
here that the cloth is not collapsing
when you lift it up in one case like
this is actually a paper towel so it's
like a pretty stiff one and this is a
very heavy and collapsible cloth and
we're able to
figure this out and adjust the simulator
simulation parameters accordingly
why would we want to do this so uh one
reason is that if we use other
approaches which use non-differentiable
simulators then what we would need to do
first is collect some simulated data so
that would take some time train some
networks that would take some time and
so here we compare with a few of the
baseline methods in terms of how much
time it takes to collect the data and
train it but with what we call diff
cloud so this approach this uses the
differentiable simulator and passes back
the gradients all the way from the point
cloud directly in 10 minutes we can be
done
as opposed to a few hours and so this is
the benefit of doing this so basically
we can get speed and hopefully we can
also get a better accuracy in some cases
so this blue
these blue bars here is the result with
the div cloud and then the other
baseline methods um on some of the
scenarios that we have they have a
little bit of higher loss
so
um
right and so these are just a few more
scenarios that we're working on right
now where uh we have tested things in
center sim kind of preliminary
experiments and we're continuing to do
this to get to the uh realty sim
right uh if anybody has questions on the
differentiable simulation part i can
answer
zoom people
yes
uh i guess like what was the um the
reason behind like moving to a point
point cloud representation over
different great yes
so um
previously and those pictures that i
showed was the you know the simulation
looked like close to reality right you
need to kind of do this by hand right so
you need to
i don't know take a picture of your
object and import the texture of that
object into the simulator right so okay
that takes me a few minutes but if i
wanted to do it fully autonomously how
would i do it so one motivation there
would be to use differentiable rendering
which renders the rgb images for you but
the problem that is when you try to do
okay real to sim then you would need to
match the actual textures of the objects
and if you have a cloth that is similar
but happens to have a different texture
okay now you have to redo that
so the one motivation here is that okay
um
doing this in a fully differentiable
manner that's great i can do everything
automatically but dealing with point
clouds is more general because now i
don't need to worry about the colors the
textures of the object and
that is actually what we're hoping to
kind of test in in the upcoming work
that we have is can we do seem to real
and then not be bothered by you know
different textures not have to like find
contrasting colors and objects and so on
yeah
yes
why do we need to
extract the point clouds from the mesh
and oh um
yes yes yes so uh this part here the
physics engine and getting the mesh
space that's differentiable right but
this is where the physics engine ends
right so if i have as an input a point
cloud it is not connected in any way to
these mesh states so i wouldn't know
let's say this point cloud here is a
little bit to the right this mesh states
are somehow a little more crumbled i
wouldn't know how to pass gradients
between them so that's why we need a
sampling method but the sampling method
needs to be differentiable and so then
we sample then you can have a loss on
this part that is the sample point cloud
and the real point cloud that is just a
simple loss like chamfer loss for
example we're just comparing two point
clouds that's differentiable but then in
order to be able to propagate back you
need to have this procedure be
differentiable yeah
all right
so
ultimately what i would like to also get
to is ability to
have
not only roboticists but contributions
from
various parts of let's say machine
learning community computer vision
community other communities that could
uh have insights into how to represent
deformables how to have a meaningful
interesting state for deformables and
how to train various policies with
deformables so because i think that um
it would be a kind of
the community effort like this would let
us train faster and be able to uh kind
of perform more advanced tasks um i
think it's important to create the
environments that other people in the
community can use very easily so for
example this is a work with my previous
group when
at kth where we have created
dynamic environments with deformable
objects that's a suite of environments
that has an open aigm interface so you
know you can uh run your favorite rl
algorithm on this plug and play uh you
it's it has fast runtime it has nice
visualizations and tensorboard and it's
pretty easy to customize so if you
wanted to create kind of new
environments that iterate on these
environments that we already have then
you can kind of introduce new materials
into this you can load custom meshes and
textures and we gave an example with
like a very
loading a very a large number of
different meshes
object meshes here
right so this is what this looks like so
it's not photorealistic but okay this is
entertaining enough uh for different
learning algorithms that for example
computer vision people can uh work with
this and it has the formables was a few
simple scenarios like for example
hanging um some sort of um
clothing item on onto a
hanger here and we've given examples of
how to uh um import existing very large
like 22 000 uh size data set of
different garments with different kinds
of um clothing items into this
we also have basic ways of generating
procedurally generating measures and so
that that's also interesting because you
can train your algorithms and test their
generalization on some objects that it
has never seen before
um and also a few tasks that are kind of
multi-stage tasks where it would be
pretty difficult for uh just like a
generic multi-framerate algorithm to
complete a task like this
and so
where we're going with this is that we
want to be able to let's say incorporate
reinforcement learning algorithms uh
into our robotics setup where a robot
does something but first we want to test
can these algorithms actually do
something useful on these kinds of
objects and after pretty extensive hyper
parameter search we i could see that for
example state of the art ppo version uh
was able to very quickly bring up this
apron to the um hanger here but it
wasn't able to hang it and we actually
observed it in most of the scenarios
that we've composed for example this bag
very easily like within very few
episodes
the algorithm would be able to bring it
up to the hook but not able to hang it
or it will be able to pull it towards
the other pole but we're not able to
kind of lift up this hoop here and
transfer it to another pole and so on
and so forth so what we would like to do
is we would like to give it out to
community and let them figure out how to
tune or create new algorithms that are
able to work with this kind of data and
of course for the robotics part what we
ultimately want to do is we want to do
some advanced scenarios that are in
for example dual arm manipulation or
something with um a robot doing
something like for example here a food
packing task where you have some
deformable objects in in the form of a
fruit and some non-deformable objects so
these are the scenarios that we've
put and made it available to the
community last year already and what
we're working on right now in uh
collaboration with meta or formerly
facebook and a few of the master
students that have joined this project
is uh putting the deformables into the
framework that is called ai habitat so
this framework was created by
meta
and their original motivation was to
create interesting visually interesting
environments where you can do mobile
navigation and mobile manipulation
but of course the deformables uh even if
they were present there in some form
they were just like fake objects there
where they did not have the deformable
physics associated with them so our task
is to be able to kind of create
some of the setups here that would be
interesting for deformables for example
spreading the tablecloth on the table or
wiping the table or hanging something on
a hanger but now in this much more
advanced uh
environment where you're actually like
in an apartment like uh set up as
opposed to just like one pole and one
item to hang
all right so
that's our
let's see yeah so so the ai habitat is
as our current ongoing work and overall
um what are the next steps for the
things that i have presented so far so
one thing that we want to do is we would
like to extend this rkhs net
approach from just looking at the
deformables to looking at generally
partially observable settings can we
extract interesting representations and
get some improvements in in those cases
and for the differentiable simulators we
would still like to expand the kind of
scenarios that we were able to deal with
because differentiable simulators
they're usually a little bit more
constrained in terms of what kind of
setups you can have there so they're not
as advanced as the lots of the black box
simulators that we've had from before um
so that's a little bit of a challenge
but yeah we would like to do this and
the other thing of course that you can
do with differentiable simulators is you
can also differentiably adjust the
policy parameters so instead of doing
reinforcement learning where you assume
that everything is black box you can
propagate back and do not only real to
sim but uh
the just policy learning general and so
after that we hopefully will be ready to
do the sim to rio and the sim to real
part would uh draw heavily on this work
with ai habitat where we would try to
basically train the algorithm over you
know many different variations of the
environment
in such a way that it's general enough
so that it can just be transferred to
hardware
okay all right
thank you very much
[Applause]
more questions questions yes you would
like questions yes yes okay i have one
about the rkhs
so are there like are there works that
take this
posterior distribution over parameters
and use them for some downstream
application
uh
like the benefit of right knowing that
would be for some sort of like control
application right or some some planning
application yes exactly so um in this
whole framework was basim
usually what we would do with bass sim
is we would um oh i wish i had a slide
i have lots of slides with this
framework where on the side you would
have a reinforcement learning algorithm
basically training on the posterior for
this simulation parameters so let me
explain a little bit uh more in depth so
what happens after one iteration of this
is you have these sorts of things which
where these distributions uh they're not
about the distribution of embedding that
i've talked about right these
distributions are the distributions over
the simulation parameters right okay so
what you can do with that is you sample
a bunch of simulation uh parameters
there and then these become your
environments on which you train your
current um learner like your
reinforcement learning algorithm right
then what you do after this is you go
back and you say okay great i've trained
now um i you can either uh
um
yeah sorry so you you go back here and
you say okay now that i've trained my uh
updated policy and simulation how well
does it perform in hardware so i run the
hardware rollout again right i infer
my posterior and then again i can
resample and retrain because now running
this on hardware has given me a kind of
new and updated information as to what
the simulation parameters should
actually be
and so you can go on and on and on like
this and ultimately this bass sim
algorithm is designed as an iterative
algorithm and precisely to enter to have
the interplay with rl um but the key
here is that depending on the
representation of the state that you
have here you would be more or less
successful inferring these parameters
and that would of course cause you to be
more or less successful in training your
own policy so that's what i mean it's a
little bit um
it's a lot of stuff all packaged at once
right but that is kind of the full
circle for you you start with a
simulation which does not align with
reality you figure out how to align it
with reality but in the process on the
side you also train the policy and so at
the end of it you get not only the
alliance simulation but also the policy
that can act in in the reality yeah
so i would think something like this
would be useful even in the second work
right because
i'm not too sure about differentiable
simulation but i assume that the physics
engine itself like has some sort of
approximations right yes that would lead
to some steady state error and after you
do gradient descent to get your
parameters so wouldn't it be still good
to have like a probabilistic estimate
even in that case it could be the
difference here is that um in this case
what you can do is you can compare
directly with the real here
so
um let's see if i can explain this
basically you can do this multiple times
here right so you will get into the
local optimum right away right but uh
you will have some sort of a policy in
that local optimum so then you can roll
out uh run uh roll out that policy and
get yourself like another real a bunch
of real observations and again compare
and again that problem now this is in
theory right in reality you would get
into a local optimum which is not very
useful and then you would need to be
innovative in order to do something and
i think you're exactly right it is
actually pretty difficult to do this
jointly when you're trying to learn the
parameters of the simulator and the
policy and we have loads and loads in
this particular area there are loads and
loads of examples where this is kind of
too unidentifiable it is very difficult
to do this jointly so you might opt out
to say something like okay great we have
shown this works really really well for
real to sim will we do reel to sim and
then we do policy learning in some other
way like for example as you're saying
using this other framework or using any
other framework right
we would still like to try doing it
either jointly or interleaving yeah but
it could be the case that this is a
little hard
thank you
more questions
also from people who are on zoom
you're also welcome to ask questions yes
please ask questions
nobody asks questions i will start
asking a question
i have an oddball question
and maybe this is a fundamental
misunderstanding so
you're
you're computing this distribution over
parameters that specify
the behavior let's say a mesh or some
some representation of a deformable
object correct
yes
okay is there
i mean could the parameters be just like
points on the mesh or is there a way to
actually just directly just represent
the deformable object as
like in an rkhs as some sort of level
set of a function or something
right so i think here um the problem is
that we don't actually fully know where
the deformable object is right so i mean
hopefully this is not too dark here but
there is something moving there right
and
we think that the deformable object is
in that area so we need some way to
represent that object okay one way to
represent this object is to i don't know
cut out a piece of the rgb i don't know
uh
image here and just use that but it's
probably gonna get some background or
something else in it right so basically
we first of all need some way to figure
out okay what representation we're going
to be using for this object and that's
precisely what this thing is about it is
saying well what we could do is we could
place a bunch of key points on this
object but instead of doing it manually
right there are algorithms that would
let us do it automatically and then
instead of using these key points
directly because i've shown how this
doesn't really succeed um with um just
using these key points directly
what we can do is we can embed these key
points and that creates for us a much
nicer representation that's permutation
invariant and smooth so basically it's a
way to represent the state of the
deformable object and what this goes
back to i think is to the very beginning
is here right so here i'm saying okay
what is the state of this object well
okay it has a bunch of i mean it's not
even a mesh because when i have a real
object i don't really have
like a known mesh associated with this
object so just so something that is
moving right either i have kind of depth
point clouds or i have an rgb image of
it so that's basically the whole point
it is one version of a representation
for an object that potentially has an
infinite degrees of freedom and
otherwise i wouldn't know how to
represent it
okay cool yeah that makes that makes
sense and clarifies uh so
would this then work
i feel like this would also work for
things like representing food or
like i think the classical question is
like the state space of an onion
right
yes nice
representing food you said
yeah i mean i guess uh what would be how
would you really like push this beyond
just a formal object um
okay maybe i need to make this clear so
i have tried to pick the most deformable
objects so like food is less deformable
than this right
means like onions being chopped going oh
you mean something that is like um
partitions objects so like particles
like go through
yeah yeah yeah so one thing that i don't
really know yet how i would handle it in
this framework is something like fluids
or smoke because there is no surface
right um
something that is an onion you could
imagine that if you don't chop it into
like you know dust but you actually have
pieces of onion right then you can keep
track of these uh pieces that end up
being there you can extract the key
points and place them there so you can
do this um where food becomes uh
particles so like porridge or you're
pouring something that i am not sure
because then the surface of the object
is kind of like everywhere in space and
so that that that i would have to
experiment with and see what happens
there but for things that are uh springy
or like that are compressible uh but
still are in a few pieces that thing
yeah that that thing could work for it
very cool thank you
ultimately another thing that i would
like to do is experiment a little bit
more with what happens with occlusions
so we had we had occlusions in in the
scenarios that we have but we haven't
kind of stress tested it like what
happens is the object is fully or like
you know almost fully occluded and then
re-emerges in something like this
so that would be interesting would be
interesting to see what happens then